welcome everybody to the annual meeting
of the
stratford-upon-avon district council
2021
before i go into the housekeeping the
first thing i'm going to do
is to remove my chain so it can be
sanitized
it is good to see people face to face uh
first time for myself for
a long time i did see the uh the cabinet
meeting for the first time this week
on on monday which was a face to face
which was a very good
arrival etc essentially
rather than prayers i've always tended
to start our meetings with
a little text and today i've chosen
one which i started with uh last
september
[Music]
it's called take time
take time to think it is the source of
power
take time to play it is a secret of
perpetual use
take time to read it is the fountain of
wisdom
take time to pray it is the greatest
power on earth
take time to love and to be loved it is
a god-given privilege
take time to be friendly it is a road to
happiness
take time to laugh it is the music of
the soul
take time to give it is a short day to
be selfish
take time to work it is the price of
success
take time to do charity it is the key to
heaven
thank you and now for some housekeeping
in the event of a fire alarm going uh
there isn't a test
scheduled while we're here so if it does
sound the fire exits are essentially
where you came in
there's one over here and there's one
around the back of those those chairs
over there
obviously we hope there will not be any
uh there are some toilets out through
the reception area where we all came in
in the event of a fire the assembly
point is the american fountain
across the road so without further ado
having made the start the first item on
the agenda
is the election of a new chairman
and it is my pleasure to propose
my vice chairman councillor ed fitter
into that role it's not been the best
year
for ed to as it were learn the ropes
because essentially with the pandemic it
has been a very quiet year
but uh essentially if i think when i
first
came to this council in 97 um some
i think it's uh 24 years ago i was
perhaps one of the
the younger members when i returned two
years ago
i realized i was the old guard so it's
nice to be handing over
uh to hopefully um subject to your
selection and support the youngest
uh counsellor to be given the honor of
becoming the chairman
since sir william uh was in uh i think
he was 37
sir william lawrence when he was the
chairman some years ago
so without further ado i will ask for a
second
to my proposal is there a seconder
council of kettle
would you like to press your uh you're
no longer muted
um i'm delighted to uh second your
proposal mr chairman for
a council official to be next year's
chairman
thank you council of kettle are there
any other nominations for chairman
thank you uh ed you are uh
suitably elected no other nominations so
essentially it's now time to sign your
declaration and to take the chain
which i hope has now been sanitized
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
guys
[Music]
now
good morning everyone i will now read
the declaration
i'll now sign the declaration of
acceptance of office
so um reverend jim edie will support our
council
as the chaplain jim is from saints
within church which is
a fantastic place in quinton and i'm
very grateful for gym's support so so
jim if you'd like to join us please
can you all hear is that better
for now
thank you thank you um thank you edward
yeah my name is uh jim edie and
i am the assistant curate in the south
warwickshire
benefits and serve the communities of
welford on avon weston haven
long marston meal vale and quinton
as you've heard i moved to me on vale
with my wife and my three children two
years ago
and it's been a joy to get to know this
part of the world
even in lockdown where perhaps it's been
a little bit more difficult but it's
certainly been a joy
and yeah it's been an honor to be asked
to be
chaplin please don't hesitate
to contact me of course i'd be delighted
to have discussions surrounding
aspects of faith but for anything else
as well
please don't hesitate to contact me
um having spent many years uh working in
the charity and community
sector in some of the more challenging
parts
of cheltenham prior to all of this
prior to call to ordination i'm aware
of the important work that councils do
and yesterday i was able to experience
first hand the work of stratford
district council as i sat in on the
first meal veil
partnership meeting hugely encouraging
so thank you to those of you that
are leading on that
for those of you who are counsellors
here
i'm also aware of the responsibility
that rests on your shoulders
responsibility to make the right
decisions on behalf of those you
represent
thank you for your willingness and
commitment to hold
this office
this year is perhaps going to be even
more of a challenge as i'm sure
difficult
decisions are going to have to be made
following the year we've just had
although coveted restrictions might be
easing
i'm sure the finances are not
therefore as you at this agm
look back over the last year but also
look forward to what is to come
a short reflection on the set new
testament reading
for this morning it's taken from one
john chapter
3 and it's verse 23 and this
is his commandments that we should
believe in the name of his son jesus
christ
and love one another just as he has
commanded us
now of course this verse itself is a
reflection of jesus's great
two great commandments to love god
and to love our neighbor as ourselves
now although jesus is clear that these
two commandments should be held together
i recognize that
here in this room there will be people
with differing opinions
on the first commandment to love god but
i would hope that we can agree
that to love our neighbor as ourselves
the second commandment
is right and good in fact
although there have been many many
challenges one of the wonderful things
that you will have all experienced and
seen over the last year in your
communities
in your streets coming together
to support each other people
showing love to their neighbor
it has been wonderful as said but as
often the case
jesus doesn't let us off that easily
he doesn't let us off with just loving
our friends the people like us the
people on our road
when he was challenged on the question
who is our neighbor
he told the parable of the good
samaritan in which the most unlikely
person
a foreigner or stranger an enemy even
showed love to a man beaten up on the
road
everyone else walked past including
the priests the priests we don't get off
lightly at all
during samaritan communities did not mix
in those days and therefore
this idea of who our neighbor is would
have been
a radical way of thinking to those
listening
and if we look further into jesus
ministry the people he healed
were outcasts the people he included
were the outsiders the people he
listened to
were the voiceless in their communities
jesus says this is what showing love
to our neighbor is
so as you venture into this new
and challenging year as you're involved
directly we're trying to rebuild
our society after such a difficult year
i encourage you to remember the radical
story of the good samaritan
the ministry of jesus and the call to
love god
and neighbor as ourselves
us pray
loving god we lift this next year to you
we pray for wisdom for decision makers
and leaders
as budgets and areas of focus are
considered
we lift to you the two charities adopted
by councillor fitter this year
life space and the heart of england
forests
thank you for their important work
and as we consider the love you have for
us
shown in the life death and resurrection
of your son
jesus christ and the love that he showed
to those he met with
i pray that in our communities
the outsider be given refuge
that the needs of the voiceless in which
we include our environment and climate
would be attended to and that's the most
vulnerable in our societies
will be put first
and to finish a simple prayer written by
john newton slave ship owner turned
abolitionist
father help us to live this day to the
full
being true to you in every way
jesus help us to give ourselves away to
others
being kind to everyone we meet
spirit help us to love the lost
proclaiming christ in all we do and say
thank you very much for your time and i
look forward to getting to know you
over the next year thank you thank you
jim
so we are one council the dreams
of our residents are our dreams their
problems
are our problems and their success is
our
success and we all share the same home
of the stratford-unhaven district
we have all gone through a very dark and
uncertain winter but we witness the love
and courage that makes our communities
so special
i am confident that our districts will
thrive and prosper
again our council and its officers have
supported those most in need
with the delivery of food parcels
financial supports and grants
finding shelter for rough sleepers and
they are involved with the testing and
vaccination centers
so thank you to the officers of
stratford and unhaven for everything
that you are doing
and our residents have made many
sacrifices have lost loved ones and face
insurgency
but they have taken care of vulnerable
neighbours and many are volunteering
again with the vaccination program
so thank you and i'm sure we send our
best wishes and encouragement to the
healthcare
providers scientists the government and
everyone involved with defeating
the disease it's good to see so many of
you here today and i want to say a
special hello to council manuela
pertiguella and to welcome you to your
first in-person council
and you'll be pleased to know that uh
counselor tony jefferson doesn't
actually live in space from
and uh from what we see from his team's
background and i'm sure we will
all miss seeing that so in council
meetings uh we must speak our minds
openly
debate our disagreements honestly but
always pursue kindness and respect for
one another
we are a great group of councillors who
have been asked to serve our communities
and the stratfor
haven district by the people so through
my work as your chairman
my first charity is live space i left
school under 10 years ago and had some
struggles that i faced alone which i
still think about today
and i hope that through our support
livespace can continue to help young
people
and to reach as many as possible
so life space provide one-to-one
mentoring for children and young people
to reduce distress
build resilience and enable them to
achieve more they create a safe time
and confidential space for children and
young people to explore the challenges
that they face
and what they want in life they are
based in stratford-haven and do
important work
and i was very pleased to learn that
counselor jill cleave is also a youth
mentor with livespace so so thank you
and i will send you all a video about
livespace later
my second organization is the heart of
human forest where i will be inviting
all councillors to join me
in some tree planting uh so planting a
tree is a great way of connecting with
our environment
and to sow the seeds of a better
stratfor chaplain even for
the future and finally to help members
officers and residents keep up to date
with what myself and the future vice
chairman are up to we have set up an
instagram account
and we'll share this with you all later
great so i'll now move to
item agenda 2. the vote of thanks to the
retiring chairman
so the council offers its sincere
congratulations and thanks to councillor
dixon
for the exemplary manner in which he
carried out the duties of chairman of
the council in 2000 2020 and 2021
councillor dixon
[Music]
the term of office dominated by the
pandemic
therefore opportunities to mix socially
across the district
were extremely restricted there was a
mop
worthy not worthy of the name or be it
that the necessary opening with the
proclamation was conducted
and a small roundabout provided rides
for the few children
for a few hours so
my comments are brief they comprise
essentially of thanks
to the many volunteers who stepped
forward throughout the pandemic
to help our communities to the staff
of sdc in getting us through the
pandemic
and personally for their donations to my
charity over two thousand pounds will be
going to the shakespeare's hospice
to the it team here again today for the
success of our virtual meetings
both for council and our various
committees
to committee services team and the
monitoring office of phil
for their endeavors to keep me on the
straight and narrow throughout all our
meetings
and to you my fellow councillors for
your support
especially with our virtual meetings and
how pleased i am to see that once again
we meet face-to-face
and hopefully very soon return to
elizabeth house for the full council
and not merely some of our committee
meetings
and finally to the most important to
claire
for her patience i feel sure that the
next year
will be so much easier for you now that
you have a tech savvy
chairman i need to say no more
and to you chairman i look forward to
planting one
or more trees because indeed a very
worthwhile
exercise so essentially
those are my comments only chairman
thank you councillor dixon i'll now move
to the next item of the agenda
um we'll give you your badge after the
session
um so we'll i'll now look uh
to elected vice chairman of the council
and i will now seek nominations for the
vice chairman
and um i would like to propose
councillor tony dixon to serve as vice
chairman i now look
to a second councillor don pembington
councillor welcome and i have
great delight in nominating councillor
tony dixon to serve as your vice chair
thank you so therefore i can announce
that councillor tony dixon is elected as
vice chairman of the council
are there any other nominations
no thanks
thank you chairman i shall now read and
sign
my declaration i tony dixon
having been elected to the office of
vice chairman of the council
of the district of stratford on avon
hereby declare that to take that office
upon myself
and will duly and faithfully fulfill the
duties of it
according to the best of my judgment and
ability
i undertake to be guided by stratford
unhaven district council's code
of members conduct in the performance of
my functions in that
office i signed this the 19th of march
of may 2021
there we are that's got to be
counter-signed by
david
apologies of absence i invite the head
of paid service to report the list of
apologies for absence
thank you chairman congratulations um
this after this morning i have apologies
from councillor adam
hazel bromage councillor eddon pence
lahincher seraphin
councillor jefferson councillor kendall
and councillor rock
thank you chairman thank you um
disclosures of interest i invite members
to make their declarations of interest
to the meeting any um interesting report
[Music]
okay so we move on to item agenda six
uh the statement of the leader of the
council so in the absence of the leader
i invite council of pemberton as deputy
leader of the council to present the
leaders reports
thank you chairman um in the absence of
the leader who is
recovering from hip surgery on the
mothership uh
i present and first of all may i say
that you now
members may turn your examination papers
over
in accordance with cabinet procedural
1.2
on behalf of the leader i present the
leaders report
which will inform the council of the
names of councillors appointed
as cabinet portfolio holders the extent
of their respective portfolios and
authority dedicated to cabinet members
with the limitations on that authority
the terms and reference of constitution
of such cabinet committees as the
cabinet appoints
and the names of councillors appointed
to them
the nature and extent of any delegation
of executive functions
the nature and extent of early
delegation to officers in addition to
that already agreed
with details of any limitation on that
delegation and the title of the officer
to whom the delegation is made
and the organizations where they
represent the council
as leader of the council are as an
alternative member the deputy leader of
the council
thank you
thank you moving on to uh item seven the
political balance and membership of
committees
so again in the absence of the leader
invite councillor pemberton as deputy
leader of the council to
apologize councillor junet can i just
respond with the uh the uh opposition
shadow
portfolio holders if i might um we've
taken the the uh model that has been put
forward
and put similar names with one exception
we've taken strategic leadership to be
myself as leader of the opposition
but we've included climate change in
that strategic leadership because we
feel that it does have a strategic role
to play we've got for resources
it is councillor david curtis for
transformation it is councillor ian
fragile
uh with some support from nate
councillor neil e eden
for public services it is councillor
jenny fragele
for holmes health and well-being it is
councillor kate rolfe with some help
as well and i will outline that to
officers for culture tourism and leisure
it is councillor manuela pertiguella
who is also to help with economic
development
place an econo economy it is night
councillor nigel rock
who also will collaborate with
councillor louis
adam who is taking the planning
portfolio shadow portfolio
role the community protection shadow
portfolio role will be councillor jill
cleve
with some help from councillor hensha
seraphin thank you
thank you council junaid
so item um seven the political balance
and membership of committees so
in the absence of the leader and why
councillor pemberton is deputy leader of
the council to introduce this item
thank you chairman and uh just uh i
would like to say uh
on behalf of the cabinet uh look forward
to working constructively with the
the shadow portfolio holders uh through
the next uh
municipal year uh members um i ask you
to
note the political balance of the
council and approve the appointment of
councillors to committees
for 2021 2022 as nominated by the
respective
political leaders
thank you
councillor wally hoggins yes um on the
on
section seven we also have
representation on the cotswold
conservation board from two councillors
here
this was formerly known as the cotswold
aomb and there are two councils here
that are represented on this it's not
listed here
that is myself and councillor barker
yeah those are those are executive
appointments
thanks councillor junet if i might i
don't know whether this is the right
place but i would like to
make a very brief statement uh about
ovue and scrutiny committee
or should i keep that to the overview
and scrutiny committee itself
could you could you perhaps just give us
an idea of what what
it's about what what it was was about a
principle because
i actually have wanted to thank the
previous two chairs
of opium scrutiny committee for the work
they did
but just to restate the principle of the
local government act 2000 and the local
localism act 2011 on the principle
on it is a d indeed a principle
uh that in this concept of scrutiny
it should ensure that where possible the
um chairmanship of a scrutiny committee
should be from
the opposition or from a non-um
non-ruling group of the council thank
you
well i'll say this as advice to the
chairman and he can decide but
i really don't think that falls within
the remit of this agenda item
okay thank you i'll take um phil
grafton's uh comments there
so um councillor barker just a
factual element and despite the fact
that it is an executive appointment the
executive appointment i have to the
cotswold national landscape is from the
county council not from this council
so councils please note that the
chairman and vice chairman of the
committees will be appointed in the
meetings that immediately follow
this council meeting so the next meeting
of the full council is on the 12th of
july
and i will now formally close this
meeting
okay so uh audit and standards committee
so i call upon
the chief executive to report the names
of those councillors appointed to serve
on the committee
only those councils called upon are able
to partake
thank you councillors we're now going to
start each of the five committees in the
appointment of the chairman and vice
chairmanship of those
five committees when i call your name
please counselors if you could stand to
indicate that you are a member
of this particular committee and it's
only those who are standing that can
partake
in the election of the chairman and vice
chairman of that this committee
um councillors crump councillor curtis
councillor dixon councillor fielding
councillor fitter councillor flytick
councillor foreman council
we have apologies from councillor
kendall councillor pertiguella
we have apologies from councillor brock
who councillor rolfe will be
substituting
thank you
move on to the next item which is the
appointment of chairman
i therefore call upon any nominations
for the chairmanship of this committee
council foreman thank you could i
propose councillor crump for chairman
please
thank you is that nomination secretary
can i second that one please
thank you councillor fielding are there
any further nominations
in the absence of any further
nominations councillor trump you're
hereby appointed chairman of the audit
and status committee
i move to you to appoint your vice
chairman thank you
thank you mr brookland uh moving swiftly
on to
appointment on vice chairman can i ask
um off of uh councillor foreman as the
vice chair of that committee thank you
again to the building and i would like
to
second that uh proposal
thank you council foreman are there any
other
proposals no thank you council the
foreman you
have been elected thank you thank you
very much uh and
that concludes the meeting the next
meeting of audit and standards committee
will take place on monday the 26th of
july thank you
thank you uh now moving on to the
employment and appointments committee uh
again i call upon the chief executive
uh to report the names of those
councillors appointed to serve on the
committee
only those councils called upon are able
to protect
thank you chairman again if you could
please stand when when i call your name
councillor alcock councillor barker
councillor cleave councillor feutic
councillor foreman councillor ian
bradgley
councillor harvey we have apologies from
councillor jefferson who councillor
shenton
is a substituting so councillor shenton
and councillor pemberton
[Music]
councillors are there any nominations
for the chairmanship of the employment
and appointments committee
that's harvey i would like to nominate
uh councillor
tony jefferson as chairman of this
committee thank you other
and i'm excited second councillor tony
jefferson
as chairman of the committee thank you
councillor barker councillor harvey
are there any further nominations
okay in which case councillor jefferson
is appointed as chairman of the
committee
as councillor jefferson is not present
today i'll continue
with the agenda and look for nominations
for the vice chairmanship of the
employment appointment committee
can i uh nominate councillor darren
pemberton
as vice chairman of this committee thank
you council harvey
and may i second councillor darren
pemberton as vice chair of this
committee
thank you council parker are there any
other nominations for vice chairmanship
okay in which councillor pemberton is
appointed as vice chair
as council as the chairman isn't here
i'll pass over to council pemberton for
the rest of the
agenda thank you thank you very much
chief executive
apologies that concludes the business of
the employment and appointments
committee
uh for today other than to note that the
net schedule meeting of this committee
is due to take place on tuesday the 6th
of july
thank you very much thank you and now
the overview and scrutiny committee and
again i call upon the chief executive to
report the names of those councillors
appointed to serve on the committee
thank you chairman um if the members of
the
overview and scrutiny committee could
please stand that's councillors crump
councillor curtis councillor fielding
councillor fitter councillor fleming
councillor foreman councillor ian
frashley
councillor juned councillor mills
councillor o'donnell and the council of
wolf
i call for any nominations for chair
do you have any nominations
okay thank you can i remind counselors
when when speaking if you could just use
your mics
it wouldn't pick up on that i'm so sorry
cheap exact
thank you so we have a nomination have
we have any seconder
yeah i'd like to second councillor pena
o'donnell for for chair
thank you councilmember are there any
further nominations
in the absence of any further
nominations i can confirm that
councillor o'donnell is the chair
of the overview scrutiny committee thank
you councilor dunham
thank you chief exec um so i'd like to
for vice chair
nominate councillor susan junard
do i have any seconders councillor
curtis thank you so
council junior looking forward to
working with you over the next year as
vice chair
that and welcome to new members of the
committee that can cl are there any
other nominations for vice chair
lovely so that concludes our business of
the ovu scrutiny committee
just to remind you members that our next
meeting is wednesday the 26th of may
thank you
thank you so moving on to the planning
committee i call upon the chief
executives report the names of those
councillors appointed to serve on the
committee
[Music]
thank you chairman we we do have a
number of apologies for the planning
committee
um councillor adam sends apologies could
councillor crump please stand
councillor curtis councillor dixon
we have apologies from councillor eden
councillor fleming
councillor henshaws evans henshaw
seraphin sen's apologies
councillor jennings councillor kendall
sends apologies
councillor mills and councillor richards
members of the planning committee having
any nominations for
the chairmanship of the planning
committee councillor fleming
yes chair i'd like to propose peter
richards as chair of the planning
committee
thank you councillor fleming are there
any seconders and i'd like to second
that mr chairman
thank you council mills are there any
further nominations for the chair of the
planning committee
in the absence of any other nominations
council richards congratulations chair
of the planning committee i'll now pass
over
to you for the rest of the meeting thank
you thank you very much executive and
thank you members for your continued
support for another term
um we do need to uh elect two vice
chairmen so we'll take
uh we'll take them on a time um i'd like
to propose
councillor fleming as one of my vice
chairman could i have a second there
please
uh i'm happy to uh second councillor
fleming uh
chairman thank you very much much
council dixon and um i would also like
to propose councillor danny kendall
as our as a vice chair do i have a
seconder for that please
okay thank you very much councillor
jennings do we have any other
nominations
no in that case we have julie appointed
council fleming and councillor kendall
as our vice chairs
remember our next meeting is on
wednesday the 26th of may
in the council chamber at 6pm you will
all have had your papers today i look
forward to seeing you then
thank you very much thank you
and the regulatory committee i call upon
the chief executive to report the names
of those councillors appointed to serve
on the committee
thank you chairman this is the last of
the committees you'll be glad to
know uh regulatory committee members if
you could please stand councillor
bromwich
actually sends apologies now councillor
curtis
councillor fielding councillor fitter
councillor jenny frenchley councillor
mills
councillor richards councillor riley
apologies from council of rock
councillor shenton
and councillor wally hoggins
members i'm looking for a nomination for
chairman of the regulatory committee
i nominate chris mills as chair of
regulatory committee
thank you council woolly hoggins do i
have a secondary yes please i like to
second
uh councillor chris mills thank you
councillorfitter are there any further
nominations for chair
congratulations council meals you've
been duly elected chair um
you now have the duty of appointing the
vice chairman and the
chairs of the planning licensing
committee thank you fine uh
now do i have the nominations of vice
chair
i i nominate councillor fitter as vice
chair
thank you thank you very much uh
sorry any other any other um
proposals for chair and vice chair
thank you very much um thank you very
much um mr chairman
um i haven't got a date for the next uh
regulatory committee but
um i'm sure we get the papers in uh have
we got a date there the
the date sorry the date of the next
regulatory committee is the 25th of june
but we do need to also appoint the three
uh licensed and panel chairman as well
thank you okay
thank you that concludes
oh sorry oh sorry i'm so sorry um
so uh licensing um chairs we have
um can i propose
uh licensing chairman for um
uh sorry can i propose ed fitter as
licensing chair you have a second third
please
i'm happy to second that thank you very
much
and we also have uh another proposal
sarah i believe i'm nominating
um your goodly self counselor mills
chair of licensing committee thank you
very much and
also sorry we you can't propose yourself
but you've had a proposal is there a
seconder for that
is there a second okay
thank you
thank you chairman i'd like to second
that thank you very much
that concludes
i'd like to propose councillor fielding
as another chair as well yeah
and i'd like to second that proposal
thank you
any other nominations
thank you that concludes thank you
thank you everyone all done
need to uh
if you indulge me just one moment please
mr chairman
absolutely thank you very much um
i'll take a swig of this
i i know that we've we've um we've uh
finished the meeting but um
i really would like to give my my thanks
um
to everybody during this uh especially
the officers during
the lockdown and on zooms and teams
and they've been so helpful to be on
especially on regulatory we've got um
caroline or her team you've got liz
uh olivia um
and uh and banks and uh
officially known as bossy boots banks
but uh she she keep
should kill me for this she keeps an
order
and also to um david buckland because
he's um kept us up to date
on what's going on on the cronus um
epidemic we've been going on but um
i i do have to take issue with um with
the chief exec
because it was just before lockdown last
year
um i happened to go into uh
into local uh supermarket
and uh into waitrose
and just get a pint of milk and it was
crowded it was really full of a lot a
lot of people
there was the um you know because it was
um
uh waitrose you're queueing up their
lobster and
quails eggs and so on just stocking up
and i noticed this furtive figure
loading up with his trolley and he got
there
500 it got 500 those little tiny
oxo vegetable oxo cubes and i said well
i think you should set an example
achieve it a second i wonder if you're
doing he said well i'm just stockpiling
thank you mr chairman thank you
customers i know the meeting has closed
but um
i just want to be able to say as the
vice chair of the ovu and scrutiny from
committee from last year that i'd like
to say a very big thanks to
justin who is along who is leaving the
authority moving elsewhere to a bigger
and better job
i wish him well but i also thank him so
much for all the effort he put in
not only to the over in scrutiny
committee but to the climate change
task and finish group so thank you very
much justin
[Applause]
and uh councillor o'donnell
thank you chair i'm so sorry justin i
didn't see you sitting there and i
dashed in but i want to express
my heartfelt thanks to you for
supporting me as a rookie chairman but
being so good at coordinating our
really varied committee and also just
making sure that we really have brought
scrutiny to the
to the forefront as we need to and we
wish you so much luck
with your new post you're going to
continue to fly career-wise and it's
going to be lovely you'll be closer to
family where you're moving to but thank
you so much
for all your help and your patience and
your empathy
thank you
you